all right let's move on
we've gone from Democrats to Republicans
and now let's talk about the devil who
apparently is our President Barack Obama
if you're not watching or if you haven't
heard of the Bible it's this very long
very preachy book and they've now put it
into a miniseries on the History Channel
and people are freaking because they
think the guy playing the devil looks
like the president let's look at the
picture and see and we can discuss
alright so there it is I don't know
which is which is that the president on
the left or the right the devil this is
a lot to think about David what are you
guys are you can't tell me that doesn't
look like Barack Obama there is some
makeup artist who was doing that who was
like oh this time we're gonna make you
yeah here we go he's played the double
before it's not his first time I don't
think they did this intentionally but
I'm sorry it's all people were talking
about today Barack Obama is the devil
his skin tone actually doesn't look like
that I mean they did change his skin
tone and you know there's there's some
facial structure there so all right one
conspiracy theorist I mean absolutely
like yes he's played the devil before
but you actually made a concerted effort
to make this man look like Barack Obama
like he actually doesn't look like that
in real life so you know I I mean
absolutely I would go ahead and say that
right that guy looks like Barack Obama
and the Emperor from Star Wars had a
baby oh is that his name yes okay now we
have two conspiracy theories Brian they
believe that the History Channel is in
on this what do you think I don't let me
tell you I think I actually had some
hippy friends of mine I'm a man of the
people and I know you know hippies Barry
jay-z's you know I guess and they said
the same thing to me like a couple years
ago how the Bible says that you know a
dark figure will will take over the
world or something like that and he was
like oh there's a there's a conspiracy
that he is at present Obama is saying
and I was like that's weird I don't know
absolutely yes being that you know they
say a dark figure will take over and and
Mark Burnett is the producer he's
married to Roma Downey I have to say I
had did a little something I would have
gone much more like this oh I don't
taking over I would have done something
like that I think that that would that
would have been a much better you know
this is a Rubin report firstly I really
needed to do this visually I just said
as soon as I saw that I was like but why
why not go Della Reese you know why not
cast Della Reese it would have saved a
lot of you know absolutely well it comes
as no surprise probably to any of you
that the History Channel is claiming
that no this was not intentional they
released a statement which i think is
kind of priceless History Channel has
the highest respect for President Obama
the series was produced with an
international and diverse cast of
respected actors it's unfortunate that
anyone made this false connection
histories the Bible is meant to
enlighten people on it's rich stories
and deep history well I guess you can't
even must be true why would a PR depart
right but maybe you think that it's
possible maybe I can see well you think
you know they did this intentionally I
have this I'm convinced there was a
conversation that went on before this
episode aired where they were like oh no
people are gonna say this Adia I don't
think they're surprised I think they
were ready for it what was funny was
that Bek glenn beck's the one who
tweeted after the show aired boy this
bears a striking Servat 'iv they're the
one that first walked it out yeah and
then Beck today tweeted oh guys you know
give it a rest media lay off it's funny
coincidental but haha not and then
Burnett retweeted Beck's tweet well
well one thing that I think is
interesting about this is that if you
guys remember in the beginning of season
two of Game of Thrones one of the heads
that they used on Spears right was
george w bush's head and you know
everyone thought it was hilarious but
now it's Obama people don't think it's
as funny is there a double standard
depending on who your guys absolutely
you're making him think like yeah George
Bush's heavens on a steak but come on I
mean
if this were George Bush as the devil
everybody would be luck at you know they
would there's honestly double standard
especially I think that's why I get so
much media play because I think in a lot
of the media Obama is sort of a savior
yeah and so bashing him it's like oh you
did what never write you're a TV and
film guide you what do you think about
you know the process that goes involved
in all this like did they just happen to
have a bush head and then you know or we
got one in storage murder or is it real
calculated decision when they make that
happen like I've discovered like working
in like the production aspect of
everything that sometimes you know
things get missed and people do things I
think with the bush head thing I think
it was like a prop guy or something
wasn't it said I'm gonna do this and be
really funny and didn't really make an
announcement about it right if I
remember correctly I'm not sure though
that's right I think with something like
this they had to have seen it like going
in that that that's that it looks like
him I'm somebody realized it but what I
have a heart what's always so worried
about these situations is that everyone
talks and things are always leaked
nowadays and I'm surprised no one on
this staff is keeping everyone on the
staff is keeping it a secret because a
bunch of people must have known about
this yeah you know I mean I just want to
know where the Bible is gonna end
how have been read that cliffhanger a
secret long don't forget the official
outfitter of the Rubin report is bonobos
calm enter code TR are two zero four
twenty percent off your next shirt